I'm eager to see Luke bosons new film
Lucy not just because I'll go see
absolutely anything with Scarlett
Johansson say what you want nanny
diaries was a tour de force I'm excited
because it looks like a slick sci-fi
actioner about a person coming to grips
with newfound superpowers ScarJo
accidentally absorb some futuristic drug
or something and goes from using ten
percent of her brain to using all of it
there by unlocking amazing ass-kicking
abilities and bizarre psychic powers
okay sidebar I hate the whole ten
percent of our brains trope that is
straight-up neurological nonsense that
was demolished by the Mythbusters now
I'll grant you that Luke the Sun
apparently only uses 10% of his brain
when he devises the plots for his films
Lucy looks as derivative as all the
others and during the slow talkie
exposition parts I'm sure I'm going to
be sitting out there charting which
movies he's feeling the most from
but I will K with all of that as long as
it has the cool comic book style action
set pieces that Poisson has proven adept
at with strong female protagonists that
he's proven that there's an audience for
and other filmmakers are getting the
message several of the best action
flicks of the past few years had female
protagonists which brings me to my main
point Lucy is proof that Marvel and DC
have been outclassed by a Frenchman
think about this Marvel has no plans to
do a black widow movie or a she hulk
movie or a Captain Marvel movie or a
movie focused on any of their other
awesome heroines and yet they're hard at
work on a blockbuster about ant-man
whose power is that he can get very
small and not even in the hilarious
Steve Martin sense DC is just as bad I'm
on record with my thoughts on how
outrageous the lack of a Wonder Woman
movie is I don't care how ridiculous I
look in that clip it's just intoxicating
to see myself with air so what's up
marvel what's up DC do you assume that
just because Catwoman an electro bomb
that people don't want to see comic book
movies with female protagonists those
movies bombed because they were terrible
and anyone using more than ten percent
of their brain knows that who would you
cast in an all female version of The
Expendables Pam Grier Michelle Yeoh
Sigourney Weaver Cynthia Rothrock tell
me your pics in the comments and
subscribe to the wire channel